everybody Sean McInnes and peanut Brown
here and in case you haven't heard the
news konami has just released about a
half hour of new metal gear solid 5
gameplay footage which you should
definitely check out here on gamespot
but before you do we want to have noted
Metal Gear Solid enthusiasts Peter Brown
the man who actually got to check out
that demo behind closed doors at e3 give
you a little run-through of some of the
things to keep an eye on ya so ground
zeroes you know the game we got back in
March some people called it a demo you
know we're not gonna argue that here but
that was supposed to be a preview of
what we're to expect in the main part of
metal gear solid 5 the phantom pain for
the first time we do get to see that
gameplay and things are actually a lot
different than what ground zero showed
us ground zeroes reinvented like seeing
some of the camera things some of the
stealth mechanics right but what we have
in the phantom pain is actually a lot of
stuff from peace walker oh really one of
the most notable things the Fulton
recovery system yeah so you know one of
things do a metal gear lives you knock
out of soldiers you can sneak past him
one thing you did in peace walker one
thing you're going to do in a pain is
abduct these soldiers by attaching a
goal balloon to their back and sending
them up to a plane which whisks them
back to your face you basically steal
them away from their previous jobs and
land them new jobs working for you
whether they like it or not yeah and
when you assign them these jobs they
actually can help you out in some ways
like they can give you info on enemy
movements on face they can help your R&D
department come up with new items that
you can use and like in an appeal but
you're not just bolting recovering
soldiers now you're also doing it to
large shipping containers okay to
vehicles such as jeeps okay in goats
bank and goat and goes now I can see the
utility of Fulton recovering a Jeep or a
car cuz that stuff that can come in
handy why would you do that to a goat a
goat is a cute loveable thing that I
guess would keep you comfy i don't know
there's i can't think of a really good
reason honestly uh but it's the thing
you can do right i mean it's one of
those goofy mechanics yeah sort of maybe
it stands in the face of a more serious
you know dramatized things about Metal
Gear but what we kind of come to expect
oh yeah I mean it's a series that's
always kind of like walked a tightrope
between very serious and very silly he
always had those undercurrents that's
it's nice to see that stuff kind of
popping up in the phantom pain yeah I
appreciate it another thing that's back
is the cardboard box but that again is
different than it's been in before so
one thing you can do like in the past
you'd have to get out of the box to do
any
now you can do is you can pop out of the
top and like tranq a guy and go back in
or you can say sneak around and have
someone actually noticed the box and get
curious and you can pop out the back
then you can sneak away so you're using
the box as a decoy so it's basically you
have more control over the cardboard
flaps on the box basically is what
you're telling me yes it's not a binary
box you're not in the box or outside the
box well you got to think outside the
boss okay I I just did that and I'm i
regret it immediately okay so the box is
just more kind of like you have more
room to finagle with in kind of like
sometimes we're halfway and it's
sometimes you know you just pop out a
little bit yeah exactly you just pop out
so yeah the box and the Fulton recovery
system or to the the biggest your
changes to the system but there are some
other oddities in there like you've got
a like let's say if you want to watch
time pass with an idea of soldiers like
different shifts throughout the day okay
you can smoke the Phantom cigar which
contains a euphemism if I've ever heard
one it contains a medicinal herbal blend
that alters your perception of time
according to the game and so we smoke in
the cigar which is an e cigar by the way
that has holographic smoke mmm you know
like you do ah basically you know Dave
change tonight 19 is a day and you can
use your little I droid and watch
soldiers movements and set little
waypoints and say okay I'll go here okay
this time of day and like that yeah
they're doing of a whole lot little
mechanics if you guys check out the
gameplay trailer demo attachment on our
site and we've got a few different
stories covering all these things as
well so check out games for more phantom
pain coverage Sean Peter thanks for
joining me thank you very much I'm gonna
go Fulton recover goat